you can be in the running you can be out
for the running but when they're running
is it new but I didn't have to do a lot
with these guys I do they'll honor me of
course and then say that coach led the
way but they did a lot of leading they
ran to live they live to run
you know when Tom and I first came to
campus his junior college transfers you
know we kind of struggled that that
first season in the transition from
junior college over to Hillsdale so in
92 was my senior season he was the last
opportunity for me as a prospective
runner in college it was all about
purpose and we knew exactly what we
wanted to do every day we actually
exposed what our training was and we
showed everybody what we were doing and
we were responsible for that or the
foundation was so much about team
chemistry and that really started that
year when coach told us we're all
hopping in bands and August and gone up
to cartman Pines out in the middle of
the sticks and some kids at camp and
somebody never camped and we went out
and trained on tank trails we had an
environment where we were living and
breathing
the sport the easiest day of the week we
used to joke hills neatnik you've done
all this volume and now you just like
I'm so glad it's Saturday I just got it
all I have to do is race you know the 92
team in particular as we came into the
national meet we knew we had something
really special going but we were there
were some glitches it is really
difficult to get five people to do
something perfectly I mean there can
always be a Ben was sick but coming into
a race there's not much else you can do
besides mess up and so here we were
these scrawny little kids from mainly
Michigan and in the Midwest and and were
competing against a team of Kenyans
it was a tough mudder not just wet
course but muddy swamp like above ankle
deep in 92 we were second in the nation
in 1993 the team was third and in 1994
they once again were second in the
nation for me as far as coach goes I
think there was just so much love I
think one he wanted to create an
environment of success long-term he's
developed quite a dynasty here in his
time but I think he also wanted to
develop young men I never thought about
the school's motto all that much you
know where to stand Tammany ggaudet but
when I look back now as we're older and
the March that we took the idea that
strength rejoices in the challenge we
all care deeply about that what I've
always wanted is to
instill in the each student-athlete the
only the desire to win and to be the
very best at what you're pursuing but to
look at that which you've been given is
a tremendous blessing from God to serve
to serve the Lord with everything we've
got with all our heart mind soul and
strength it was never really about me
and the glory it was just about the team
and we weren't supposed to do that that
was kind of one of those days where when
you get all done and you're really smile
from ear to ear
and every
together it was it was a great day you
know I was gonna I was gonna be all in
and I was all in because they were
inspiring me and
they were definitely definitely all-in
you